hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar accelerating Discovery together
Community Resources for multiplexed
Imaging of diverse tissues
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Leica Microsystems
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit Leica Dash microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
with that I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Dr Andrea J Radke associate
scientists center for advanced tissue
Imaging
niaid NIH Andrea you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you so much for the very kind
introduction it's an absolute honor and
pleasure to be with all of you today uh
talking about things that I'm very
passionate about both Multiplex tissue
Imaging and sharing this knowledge with
all of you and others around the world
and so
um let's let's begin so let's start
first with a history lesson and probably
also a mispronounced last name so you
know here we are in 2023 but hundreds of
years ago Marcelo malpigai recognized
the importance of microscopy and
Medicine in fact he was the first to
actually apply these techniques to study
both human and insect anatomy so he's
credited with applying microscopy to
Medicine understandably leading to Major
advances in human as I said and insect
anatomy histology and plant biology
key is credited with discovering
capillaries and the two compartment
system of the human spleen but haters
are going to hate in 2023 and also in
the 1600s and in so doing he offended
his peers and this is a quote taken from
one of the the treatments of his work by
his peers saying it is our firm opinion
that the anatomy of the exceedingly
small internal confirmation of the
viscera which has been extolled in these
very times is of use to no physician boy
were they wrong and so now in modern day
you can see just the expansion of
technologies that now allow dozens of
markers to be visualized in human and
mouse tissues at single cell and spatial
resolution and that's what I'm going to
be talking to you about today and here's
just showing you a human lymph node that
was used to create that Cathedral of
science that stained glass window on my
cover slide
um that this is the the source data
where you can see the terminal centers
in the top right rows uh and the
medullary chords of the lymph node
and so there are many many different
approaches to looking at spatially
resolved and and single cells and
tissues and the architecture of these
tissues and we call these Multiplex
antibody-based Imaging platforms so
today I'm just going to be focusing on
spatial mapping using protein targets
and antibodies and there's many
different methods that use four four
labeled antibodies so the little y in
the top left are our antibodies and so
this is a nice summary of the four floor
labeled methods there's methods that
employ DNA labeled antibodies as
summarized in the middle compartment of
this figure and then metal labeled
antibodies and then in the methods that
are summarized here and so this just
putting in the lower right hand corner a
really great reference that we wrote
with our colleagues within the Human
biomolecular Atlas program and so I just
refer you that as a resource for
learning more about these methods
and so again putting back the historical
element in the last 20 years we've seen
an expansion of these Technologies so
I've used this timeline to denote the
different names of the Technologies and
if the first description of these in the
literature or the founding of a company
and the take-home message is that it
just it's a constant drum beat new and
new technologies and so it's very
exciting and 2023 we imagine a year of
adoption and expansion through
commercialization and also through
Community efforts to get more and more
people using these Technologies
and so martello and all of you probably
realize that these techniques have great
promise and so summarized here that we
can look at tissue organization granular
cell type cell State stromal and myeloid
cells even discover rare and new cells
and look at spatial relationships and
cellular components and I'll show you
that uh throughout the the talk and so
as I said you can look at anatomical
structures just shown here the purple
b-cell follicle the cyan pericortex and
the lymph node we can look at granular
cell phenotypes with a different marker
expression depending on the antibodies
that you use in your panels we can also
look at cell States if you use the
appropriate antibody so we can here is
showing dividing cells expressing ki-67
we can look because we're looking at
intact tissues we can look at entire
mesh works of the follicular dendritic
cells these stromal cells that are under
sampled by other means while also
looking at myeloid cells and the
relationships with cells in this case
the germinal center so you see these
beautiful cells gobbling up dead cells
and in the germinal center and because
again we're keeping the tissues intact
we can look at rare cells that you might
miss through other methods and just
highlighting that we see these Exquisite
cd25 these magenta myeloid cells that
are at this TB the T cell and T Cell
border and they're making contacts with
regulatory cells so these images can
lead to really hypothesis generation so
a lot of promises with these
Technologies as summarized on this slide
but nothing is free in life and so
there's a lot of pitfalls in the in the
sense that these Technologies require a
lot of time validating the antibodies
can take you know six to eight months
which will show you in the later part of
the talk they're very costly the average
antibody might be 150 to a thousand U.S
dollars and then there's incredible
incredible technical challenges and
expertise required to really have
confidence in the data that is being
generated
and so today I've organized the talk to
first talk about the promise and
applications of this approach and then
two talk about Community initiatives
that will really reduce the time cost
and Technical burdens of these methods
allowing more people to participate in
spatial mapping that is really the goal
and so uh coming back to this slide to
just Orient you the methods that I'll be
telling talking to you about today
employ fluorophore labeled antibodies
and the method is called Ibex so it
involves cyclic staining and cyclic
Imaging and so here's the summary on the
left is showing that by now we've we've
developed both a manual and an automated
version of the method and Ibex stands
for iterative bleaching extends
multiplexity so if you're wondering
that's what it means and it's the cyclic
Imaging method where we apply
fluorescently labeled antibodies in the
top shown there antibody label image die
inactivate and then repeat and so you've
seen that we validate a lot of reagents
fluorescent probes diverse microscope
configurations while maintaining all
open source and open Panel development
and want to acknowledge that science is
a team sport so really pitching the need
to work together and acknowledging all
the wonderful young investigators Evelyn
Rochelle Rebecca these students who've
worked with me over the years uh and
then my colleagues Anita Emily and Colin
who've been really uh integral to this
along with members of the Germain lab
and so highlighting that this is
published work now so you can find this
in the in our first paper that where we
really demonstrated the application of
these Technologies to looking at Mouse
tissues and studying immune cells and
mouse tissues then we've extended it to
look at you can show that Ibex is
compatible with animals that have
fluorescent proteins so that's important
for some of the work that many of you
might be doing and showing that we
didn't see a loss of the fluorescent
proteins after rounds of Imaging
and then in fact you could with the
right multiplexing you could image
around it in other words you could keep
your reporter proteins as fiducials and
then add other antibodies and af647 and
AF Alexa Force 700 conjugates to
phenotype the cells in in Greater
granularity in those tissues so a lot of
Versatility that's a take-home message a
lot of Versatility and going through
this quickly because this is published
um and we refer you to those
Publications we've extended this to the
human many different human tissues
showing as a proof of concept anywhere
from 16 to 65 Plex and seven human
organs and six murine organs and that's
what's published and certainly a lot
more is underway
in the last year we really wanted to
focus on taking the more tedious
components of the protocol which include
working from steps one to three where
we're we're doing the uh immunolabeling
and dying activation we in order to
scale we delivered these Solutions using
a fluidics device instead of taking the
sample and then soaking off the cover
slip before the dying activation we
actually keep everything on the
microscope stage uh and then in summary
what we've created is an open system
that has many advantages both cost and
time while maintaining versatility and
being able to use primary and secondary
antibodies and diverse tissue
preservation methods both fixed Frozen
and ffpe so the overall workflow is
again we're keeping everything on the
microscope slide so if you look at the
microscope and then the blown out
version and panel B we can see that we
coach the samples
on a coated cupboard we sorry we section
the tissue onto a coated cover slip have
an Imaging taper that you can buy off
the shelf we use a microfluidic system
again to deliver those antibody
cocktails or Dine activation solution
and then interface Control software
which we report in our paper that allows
you to do the antibody labeling Imaging
dying activation all fully automated and
really want to acknowledge the
tremendous efforts of Colin Chu who's a
visiting fellow at the time and James
Marr from Leica Microsystems that
integrated the microscope with the
fluidic system
so again more details on that are in our
nature protocols and just showing you
the quality of images that we can obtain
so here's an example jejunum showing
single cell resolution both of the
cytoplasmic proteins such as cd49a and
vementin and the nuclear marker host
um and then importantly and this is a
major theme of the day is that you can
capture whole slide regions so we want
to be able to capture very very large
regions as shown on the image of the
human ffpe kidney on the right and we
want to capture these very large regions
at high resolution with sufficient
dynamic range and in a time
time time efficient manner and so the
typical image properties are for our
both manual and automated Ibex methods
are shown on the left there
and then
because the method is cyclic so you do
these iterative rounds of images when I
look at the figure on the left showing
the Stacked images of the red circles
the yellow circles and and the in the
cyan and green we those are to show you
that we need to have a common marker
fiducial which we then align those those
individual panels to get a full stack of
across all the the Imaging rounds at
pixel pixel resolution and that is
afforded we're able to do that through
open software developed by zivyaniff and
Brad lowenkamp using simple itk and
we've reported all this in zenodo on a
public data Repository
and so in this first half of the talk
and when you know going through the
methods going through the promise and
now the application so we really the
first big application was to explore the
tumor microenvironment of normal and
malignant lymph nodes this of course
again harping on the the fact that
science is a team sport you can see
there's a lot of authors on this
pre-print and I'm really grateful for my
NIH colleagues and my Boston Jean
colleagues and tackling this challenging
problem and so on the left showing you
that you know it's well appreciated that
there are cell intrinsic and extrinsic
factors that govern progression and
follicular lymphoma and and really the
environment is so critical uh for the
survival and uh and growth of the tumor
B cells and so we used a multi-ohmic
approach to create an atlas of these
normal and flicker lymphoma lymph nodes
so on the right just showing you that in
the study to really Advance the
technical integration we're looking at
non-filicular lymphoma we're looking at
non-follicular lymph nodes and then
follicular lymphoma lymph nodes all
excisional biopsies which is we're
grateful to have that kind of quality
and amount of tissue to do these assays
we employed multiple different methods
including bulk rna-seq single cell
rna-seq Ibex which I just showed you you
know highly multiplexed and reasonably
large regions of interest of 10 on
average of 10 millimeters squared and
then I took the most important markers
uh you know paired them down to a series
of panels that I could apply to much
larger regions of interest and ffpe
samples so getting it to be more
clinically relevant and that's what the
mix if is and so you're familiar with
Ibex now again it's we're performing
this the manual method in the Imaging
chamber using rounds of antibody
labeling Imaging dye inactivation
keeping one or two markers as a fiducial
show that little red circle and then
antibody labeling and imaging again
and the markers that we used in our
panels are shown here we've got markers
for tumor B cells one for alignment and
registration and segmentation a lot of
markers for immune cells because it's
been reported that the immune cells
stromal and myeloid cells are so
critical for tumor progression and then
the asterisk denotes that we applied
these markers also to the mix if Imaging
and so this is just a summary of the
individual methods on the left showing
uh in panel e the bulk rna-seq the
Single Cell rna-seq Ibex and mix if you
can see that we can obtain genomic
information from the RNA sequencing
approaches all methods afford varying
degrees of looking at the cellular
composition of the tumor
microenvironment clonotypes are really
unique for Unique information provided
by the RNA sequencing and that the
Single Cell approaches both single cell
rna-seq and Ibex allowed us granular
cellular phenotyping but finally to
really understand the mileage stromal
rare cells and spatial patterns of these
tissues we needed to use spatial
approaches both the Ibex and then
confirmation with the mix if
and so again this is published and I
want to give plenty of time for the
second half of the talk so I'll go sort
of quickly through this just to show you
that when we take the images that are
acquired by ivex and we do object-based
segmentation across these 10 samples
and then it's displayed these individual
single cells are displayed in a umap you
can appreciate the very diverse
phenotypes uh and and also the richness
of the data in terms of the number of
segmented cells highlighted in that
light blue color with each umap so you
can see across the samples we can look
at flavors of B cells different tumor
tumor types based on the expression of
the markers bcl2 and cd10 irf4 for
signaling and then many many populations
of T cells as I highlighted you know the
different granular phenotyping that one
can do with the right markers as well as
myeloid and stromal cells and
importantly we can then quantify these
across the sample so showing here that
we can look across the samples and you
know turning on disease progression for
the B cells the T cells and then for the
myeloid cells we treated them a little
bit differently using a pixel based
tessellation mask to get at the richness
of the data summarizing across the whole
samples again these were very much
undersampled using other methods
as well as looking at the stromal
subtypes on the on the low on the
um I guess would be the x-axis so to
speak showing you all the different
markers that are used for those
tessellation masks and then we're
quantifying it
um across the whole sample so a lot of
information can be is available to us by
applying these highly multiplexed
Imaging and then using uh appropriate
analytical means to get after uh
insights into tumor progression and so
in the last leg of the tour really been
focusing on extending our initial
findings in this uh this cohort to a
larger validation cohort and in order to
do this we partnered up with the cell
dive Imaging team and there was so as I
highlighted in this introductory slide
that both are used fluorescently labeled
antibodies and so they share many
properties and so uh just highlighting
as I go further they're
fluorescent-based cyclic Imaging both
you use both cell dive and Ibex use dye
inactivation to achieve High Multiplex
and so by pairing the two we were able
to use the imager with our die in
activation solution that is gentle on
the tissue and allows us to use those 61
fluorescent probes that we've been
testing with many more in the pipeline
importantly I'm going to another point
of emphasis the need to capture whole
slide images but also being open to
antibodies from multiple vendors and so
is tea size if and cell dive and Ibex
all offer you that opportunity
as you'll see why we need to do that and
then we also need to image many dozens
of markers in a single tissue section so
I've shown that to you before and that's
why these Technologies are attractive
working with ffpe tissues to be
clinically relevant of course and then
capturing those large regions of
interest at high resolution
and so on the right is showing you these
are the cell dive channels that are
afforded on the instrument and then the
fluorophores that we can use that we've
benchmarked for Ibex and I just so we
can see that this is easy to Plug and
Play and want to thank the people
Melinda Michael Rick and prachi for
their help in integrating the cell dive
in ibex
and so here's just giving you a walk
through you know we talk a lot about
building the markers and how do we get
the images and why do we need is
probably what many of you are interested
in and why is open the best way to go so
here's the case the bcl2 shown in blue
which is labeling the mantle zone of the
B cell follicles
we are able to by using both a cell dive
and Ibex use a clone that's preferred by
the pathologist so we have confidence in
the data and then amplifying it to get
an excellent signal to noise so that's
very important
um but because it's flexible Ibex we use
direct and indirect antibodies I could
import all that flexibility to the cell
dive platform and we have a beautiful
cd8 that's a direct conjugate and that's
compatible with the full panel uh then
you know showing we're really interested
in follicular dendritic cells because
that's extremely relevant for flicker
lymphoma showing with this you know this
antibody we can use a direct conjugate
we can use a PE conjugate which is
compatible with Ibex and testing many
different antigen retrieval conditions
and clones to get the best signal and so
that's that's why the cost and time
comes in and the expertise is a lot of
iteration a lot of iterating and
tinkering but really pleased with the
results in the in the long run and then
additionally showing the ki-67 that this
particular antibody we want to look at
the South states are these cells
dividing that it was dim there's a need
to amplify so you can't perhaps achieve
this with other methods and I actually
had to use tryptophan and then that was
working with multiple rabbit antibodies
so that's really the anatomy of an image
the nuts and bolts just with those four
specific examples and then in just
summary extending to a little bit more
advanced but still a simple example so
you know not to overload you it's just
the 10 markers shown on the left I test
maybe 17 different antibodies from an
ultimately Source antibodies from Seven
vendors and it took me a total of four
of six weeks and again using the
pathologist's preferred clone the
ability to amplify or use Direct
conjugates that's all very important and
that's what's available with those open
Platforms in addition to being open we
really want to get after the tumor
heterogeneity which we know is a big
component of the disease and so here I
just show you a very large you know
sorry zoomed in region of a cyan
follicle so A B cell follicle
pseudo-colored inside as I mentioned and
then the beautiful extracellular Matrix
labeled by lumacan in magenta and again
with imaging we can look at an acellular
components that would be impossible
through other approaches and of course
we can also look at the whole
architecture and and and how they
remodel the stromal remodeling that
takes place in many disease States so
another win for Imaging
but when I then zoom out and show you
that this is just a small region taken
from a much larger sample again kudos to
our clinicians for getting excisional
biopsies you can see that there's great
heterogeneity and so that particular
image there was a lot of extracellular
Matrix as denoted by the intense lumican
in magenta but in other regions of the
sample there is no extracellular Matrix
so that's you want to make sure that
you're capturing as best you can the
real scenario and you need to do that
through whole Side Imaging and we had in
our preprint before integrating with the
cell dive we had shown that in the mix
iaf where we could capture much larger
regions of Interest how similar were
that was the community composition to
the smaller regions that we captured
with Ibex and we did have a a pretty
good correlation about 80 80 to to under
95 correlation based on the community
composition so we were happy with that
and so then finally you know just
showing there's not only just within the
tumor credible heterogeneity there's
even more heterogeneity across samples
and so that's what we're working with
our validation cohort and I just
visually display to you and and
pseudo-colored and Wild colors just
showing you all the different samples
arrayed here that there's differences
you'll see immediately appreciate
differences in the size of the follicles
the shape of the follicles the amount of
extracellular Matrix like these samples
are very very different and we want to
capture that difference and understand
why it's different and then in the hopes
of creating better Therapeutics or uh
you know targets for the patients
especially those most vulnerable
so now we're and we could do that again
with the cell dive uh Ibex integration
so now we're transitioning to part two
of the talk to talk about how while
these are very promising Technologies
there's still a lot of barriers I I have
10 plus years of multiplexed Imaging
experience that's a that's a big plus
and but I really want to share what I've
learned from my peers and and my
colleagues with all of you so that it
can reduce again those those entries uh
that you can accelerate Discovery by
reducing the time and cost of validating
antibodies and the technical challenges
that come with these Advanced microscopy
techniques and so again I refer to one
of our favorite uh articles written by
our colleagues within the Human
biomolecular Atlas program that this
figure uh in the in the perspective
nicely outlines I think the pain points
of Multiplex antibody-based Imaging
first want to alert you to the time
scale you know weeks to months weeks to
months weeks months to years right
that's true and many of you probably
have already experienced that and so the
steps of doing you know acquiring those
arrays of samples starts with marker
selection you need to have the right
markers for your cell types identify
what tissue preservation method you'll
be doing and then find appropriate
antibodies
then step two you need to validate those
antibodies using appropriate controls
sometimes you need to amplify and then
compare with traditional Imaging so
that's all highlighted in step two then
you have to work on validating that full
panel showing that there's no
non-specific interactions or
interactions between your antibodies as
shown as step three and that can take
weeks and then the data analysis which I
don't talk about and there's many
wonderful resources to learn more about
that and that's a rapidly evolving field
even more so than Multiplex
antibody-based Imaging I think but I
want to acknowledge that that's
absolutely true painful truth months to
years so that's a that's a field in need
of a breakthrough and so just taking the
next few minutes to highlight in the
review uh where you could find resources
so if you're looking to find cell types
and and what Mark markers you can use to
phenotype certain cells in your tissues
there's a lot of great resources and
this is in table S2 where we shared
these Gene and protein databases from
marker Discovery effort it's
if you're looking for appropriate
antibodies for your tissue preservation
and Method Of Interest we refer you to
supplementary table S3 that lists the
antibody search engines and so that can
be a great resource to you
and then a huge you know if one of my
top questions that I get is you know how
do you control for autofluorescence and
the answer is you really embrace it uh
and this is a table that's five that
that I prepared that shows you all the
sources of autofluorescence which are
really painful in fluorescence-based
approaches such as Ibex and you know the
summary of this figure for me is that
ways you know influence the best the
biggest impact you can have on
autofluorescence is to prevent it by how
you preserve your tissue and it'll show
that that to you in the next slide and
if you don't have a choice say you're
working with ffpe tissues then try to do
that with computational means or amplify
your signal as I indicated that you
might need to do and then with the cell
dive how they subtract the the
background you know the autofluorescence
correction is a huge win and and we do
that as well with our Ibex method so
it's a nice it's a good resource for you
guys this table I think
and so as I mentioned how if you can
control and so this is there's a movie
on the left so you can now have control
to play this on your end so if you push
the little triangle in the middle this
will just show you a volume image uh
that uh is acquired with the c3d
clearing solution and the point here is
that what I'll show you in the next
slide is that how you prepare the tissue
is so critical so over the years we've
developed an optimal tissue preservation
protocol within the Germain lab and
showing you that this method involves
fixed Frozen tissues it preserves the
tissue architecture and cellular
morphology as you've seen that with the
images I've shown you it's a milder
fixative so you you don't have as much
cross linking and you don't need to do
antigen retrieval and you can use many
of the antibodies that you employ for
flow cytometry so that also reduce your
total reagent cost in the lab and I
think that's an important consideration
we've tested now many more and you'll
see many more commercial antibodies and
we reduce the autofluorescence from
common sources which include red blood
cells and tissue lipids and importantly
these tissues archivable
and as why I wanted to encourage you to
play the video is that you can take
these tissues that you've frozen and
then you can prepare them using volume
Imaging later so it's a good way to
Archive your samples and then you can
even do more complex Advanced microscopy
in 3D later and that's what's in the
movie
so now I want to share something that's
been under development for two years and
we really just released it in the last
month it's the Ibex Imaging Community
where we really want to share successes
and failures in life we have a lot of
failure but we don't really have a means
to share those failures to teach
ourselves and others and so our guiding
principles is shared ownership and so
I'll show you I'll I'll tell you and
then I'll show you soon uh it's failure
teaches success again we learn we want
to learn from uh troubleshooting but we
want to learn from others
troubleshooting stewardship and
democracy democratization is very
important I told you how costly both in
time and resources these methods are and
we want to share what we know so that we
can accelerate Discovery for others
while maintaining our commitment to
Excellence generating high quality data
that everybody has you know that we have
confidence in the results that come from
these images and then that we can
iterate together you know that science
is a team sport and when you pair up you
can do a lot more than what you could do
by yourself and so here you know just
showing you now is our QR code that has
a mountain so if you scan it on your on
your computer or sorry on your cell
phone you should be able to go to the
Ibex Imaging Community website and the
the logo is a mountain uh because the
Ibex stands for you know that's the
method iterate bleaching extends
multiplexity but it's also a goat a goat
that's able to climb exceedingly high
mountains and um that's how it feels
like with these high Plex imagings many
times so anyway it's an inspiration to
reach the summit together
and so here again showing you here's our
goat Banner if you go to that Ibex
Imaging Community through that QR code
you'll come upon this static site but
it's not a website I mean ziv who is
instrumental in building all of this he
always tells me that it's not a data set
sorry it's not a site it's a data set
and you can download that data set from
zonodo
um and I'll tell you I'll show you how
to do that soon
and what is covered in here well so we
said we include uh you know we're
supporting many different methods these
are 2D methods that what we Define as
tissue sections that are maybe five to
Thirty Micron sections they could be
fixed rows and or ffp or many many
different methods uh tissue preservation
methods we do you know Multiplex 2D
those are your standard non-iterative
maybe four to eight markers we also
support Ibex of course as the name
implies but I really want to use this
slide to say it's not just Ibex we also
have 3D methods so those are the larger
volumes which I showed you in that video
that you played earlier where you can go
from 200 microns to three millimeters so
there's a clearing enhanced 3D imaging
method developed by colleagues in the
Germain lab that allow four to eight
markers in one image and then there's
the c3d Ibex which is underway and
developed by Hiroshi and mondo and other
colleagues in the in the Germain lab
where it applies c3d and Ibex to do more
markers in the total volume about 15
markers so that's very much underway but
this is what you can find in the Ibex
Imaging Community along with now also
the integration of the Ibex cell type or
cell dive ibex
and so why all these methods and is
because antibodies validated for one
method will likely work in others and so
starting with the multiplex 2D if you
have an antibody for a T Cell marker
benchmarked in a non-iterative method it
will likely work for Ibex it will likely
work for c3d and meth antibodies that
work for c3d will of course then work
for c3d Ibex or high likelihood uh same
thing with ibix those antibodies will
also work and then finally the multiplex
2D you know many of those Target
antibodies could work directly for c3d
ibex
however antibodies that don't work for
Multiplex 2D that's kind of really the
stumbling block will not likely work in
others so that's why we include all
these methods and and also just to
showcase the work uh in the spatial
biology field and so you know if you
have any questions you can get in
contact with us
uh and so now we're getting to the point
where we have a movie so that's just to
remind me that there's a movie on board
so now I'm going to jump to the movie
I'm going to push play here
and yeah so here's me walking through
the actual knowledge base
um so as I mentioned it's a data set
that you can have access to through
zenodo a public data repository and with
the shared ownership a major point the
guiding principle if you contribute to
the knowledge base then you are named on
the zenodo entry and then as I mentioned
it's a data set we want you to download
it so everything that's statically
displayed on that site you can obtain
here which includes the reagent
resources CSV title images when we
upload more images the supporting
material
again with the shared ownership when you
go to the actual site generated from the
data set you can see all the Junior and
senior investigators from around the
world who've already contributed their
knowledge to the uh to the to the site
and we're very grateful and appreciative
of their efforts and we also acknowledge
that you may not feel comfortable with
sharing especially unpublished work so
only share what you feel comfortable
with and if you have any questions
please reach out and so here's an
overview we've got our lovely goats a
very inspiring totem and there's our
principles and really much we want you
to take pride in what you are building
with us so you can get those logos
um and and use them in your talks and
presentations
Now You See Me motioning in the cursor
uh and so
okay we'll let it go next
um
great and just the next part uh the
reagent resources this is probably we're
going to spend most of your time these
are where you can find reagents uh
relevant for Multiplex tissue Imaging
again with the different methods that I
described if you first go and drop down
we support not just primary and
secondary antibodies but many other
accessories that are important for
Multiplex Imaging including blocking
kids we want to add conjugation kids
Xenon labeling kits here's where you can
sort by Target so this is targeting a
particular protein you can see we have
many many many uh entries in here
here you can search by Target species I
mean the majority are human because the
work of building those you know spatial
mapping for human reference Atlas but we
also have a lot of mouse antibodies and
we want to add with your help other
experimental model systems and then the
other fields are really pretty much
boilerplate antibody metadata which were
created in partnership with our
colleagues in the infinity reagent
Imaging and validation work group of
hubmap it's important we make a lot of
custom conjugates so you want to sort
for what might be available to you
support many many methods as I outlined
earlier tissue preservation because
that's so critical for antibody
performance so we want you to record
those details here and you can search by
and uh tissue preservation method to
find antibodies that will work for your
particular samples Target tissue so
again demonstrating that Ibex and the
many of these methods are compatible
with different tissues and tissue States
so many of the antibodies you know for
example would only work in a
tuberculosis infected sample and that's
a you know provides a good control
tissue to Benchmark these these
antibodies so that's why we want to
record the state the detergent this is
you know the devil's in the details this
we have observed a difference in
antibody Performance Based on the
detergent used in your blocking and
staining buffers antigen retrieval
conditions are so critical as well as
for the iterative methods ivex and c3d
Ibex the die in activation conditions
for that fluorophore we want to provide
both reagents that work and then don't
work which is kind of a novelty and why
we say don't and that's a pretty that's
a loaded term but recommended for those
conditions for that tissue preservation
method for that detergent for those
antigen retrieval conditions and then we
also want to create a mechanism for
self-correction where individuals can
agree yes that worked for me with those
settings that you laid out or no that
did not work for me when you click on an
individual Target you'll see the listing
here this is a supplementary material
yeah
you've got our Orchid we want to give
credit where credit is due so the person
who contributors name there and I'll
link to their Orchid page you can have
your Publications here so it's a great
work way to Showcase your excellent work
and then you know you can also include
notes about what did you do to validate
this antibody which tissues uh
validation
um you know positive and negative
controls you can see the difference here
when I'm reporting
is uh you know we love images so the
difference on the antigen retrieval
conditions same antibody the cd21pe
conjugate if I do pH 6 to 9 I get a
different uh different result versus
just pH six so we want those details
here to help other people get the best
quality images
and so what was interesting
to me is how even at the lab this is
where you know these antibodies are all
validated by the the vendor so we want
to appreciate the work that they do in
validating that but if you take the same
clone here for cd11b and human tissues
um and then you'll watch as I scroll
over here and the in the reagent
resources table that my colleague had
validated it using an antigen retrieval
ph9 and he says that has worked nicely
for him but I tried it with a pH 6 shown
here and also in the human tonsil and I
don't recommend it with those conditions
so that antibody works when pH 9.5 but
not pH 6 and instead then if I had to
use ffpe and pH 6 I would recommend the
Clones indicated there so that's the
kind of information that's here along
with protocols and so this just got
launched and so we want to share more
protocols again of what works what
doesn't work
and then because we're using GitHub to
both as a mechanism to share the data we
have a discussion forum so this is also
where you can interact with us through
contributing uh your reagents but also
asking a question
um and so that's what's all included in
the knowledge base tour and in the final
minutes I'll talk about another
Community initiative taking place in
hubmap so having talked to you about the
Ibex Imaging Community that's one
Community initiative that's really
focused on sharing reagents software
Hardware related to Ibex and other
Multiplex Imaging methods I want to talk
to you about another Community effort
that is taking place within the Human
biomolecular Atlas program that involves
creating these organ mapping antibody
panels and addressing pain points shown
on the slide on the part of the slide on
the left and so you can see as I
highlighted earlier that it's very it
requires a lot of expertise and time to
identify the right markers to to
phenotype cells and find appropriate
antibodies and then validate those
antibodies in the full panel and so
there's o maps created by the Human
biomolecular Atlas program are
collections of antibodies that Define
cell populations and anatomical
structures and human tissues that are
relevant for spatial mapping in support
of a human reference Atlas and again
these are developed by my colleagues
Within hubmap
and so you know it starts with the first
courageous group to build these seven o
Maps uh that's where we started and just
highlighting the tremendous work of our
team on the left with Liz John Gloria's
team Elizabeth Anna Prussia and then
Ellen Christopher and Diane and Ellen
was instrumental in developing all the
website and support materials and uh so
sop with me as well as Diane and so
we're excited that this work will appear
and press and nature methods and um so
and panel a just showing you know we
asked our omap authors our experts in
Multiplex Imaging Fourier seven tissues
of Interest the intestine lymph node
lung kidney liver skin and pancreas for
your various panels how many anatomical
structures and cell types can you can
you phenotype using those panels and you
can see that our Mark our Multiplex
Imaging panels may be anywhere from 12
to 52 markers showing the BP
um as I highlighted to this a lot of
expertise to develop these techniques uh
develop these panels rather but cost and
time and so we average six to eight
months to develop an omap and we asked
our authors you know how much money do
you spend on just antibodies alone for
your organ mapping antibody panels and
so you know it's regardless of the
method whether they use DNA 404 or metal
labeled antibodies that there's
tremendous costs anywhere from Thirty to
eighty thousand dollars due to the rigor
of validating finding and validating
antibodies for your method and however
when we asked our authors how much does
it cost you know 100 tests to use a
developed home app that cost comes
considerably down that Delta is the
valley of community and sharing
knowledge related to spatial mapping
and so using this figure prepared by
Diane Saunders to walk through the steps
of an omap as this is we feel to be a
very important resource for the
community as I mentioned before you
first have to find your right markers
and we ask to identify at least 10
protein biomarkers an omap is at least
10 protein tarkers targets that allow
you to look at the anatomical structure
of cell types and your in your tissue of
Interest
there's a lot of great resources for
antibody selection including the Ibex
Imaging community and the antibody
validation reports that are going to be
soon to be hosted by the hubmap so
there's and as long as as well as
databases defining antibodies then you
have to validate the antibodies as we
mentioned the rigor that goes into that
and then validate the full panel which
as highlighted before involves
eliminating those non-specific
interactions looking at the performance
of the antibody across cycles and
adjusting exposure times and so in the
end you have what's needed to publish an
omap and get it marked with a digital
object a fire requires an omap table an
omap description and the antibody
validation reports along with review so
those are all the details if you're
interested you can certainly Reach Out
we'd love to have you it's open not just
to people in Academia and government but
also in Industry we have an industry LED
uh omap coming soon with uh from
miltenny and so just highlighting in
December 2021 we had one 100 map and a
few months we had seven o Maps we in the
last year we completely redid the
supporting material to get version 2.0
and soon we'll have six new omaps for a
total of 13 with 20 omaps coming and
vetted for the end of the year and so
with that I just want to acknowledge the
many many people that contributed to
this work
especially Ron for providing such a
fruitful environment and all our support
from our colleagues listed here
and I'll take questions happy to take
questions and thank you very much for
your interest
thank you
great well thank you guys so much for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right so let's get started
okay great our first question asks what
are the biggest challenges for adopting
Ibex or other methods in the laboratory
okay
you with us Andrea
I think I have audio and I think I have
video but honestly I'm driving blind
okay but Kaylee is saying chat so you
know what hey we okay you can hear me
great hello okay
um so this will be exciting uh it's
always a challenge so thank you guys for
for tuning in it's really a pleasure uh
one of the first questions it's uh from
one of my friends so it's a real honor
to answer his question uh but it's also
a sailor failure and success story so my
friend Josh thank you Josh uh and part
of the community asked what's the story
behind the stained glass window well I'm
really glad you asked it it's obviously
very deeply personal to me
um I'll say because we're in the topic
about sharing failures I created that
artwork during a very dark period of of
my life it was uh Thanksgiving 2020
everybody was pretty depressed honestly
so
um just sharing that that you can have
scientific successes and failures but
also um personal successes and failures
and so anyway that was a way to focus me
to work on something quite pretty and
impactful and to me there's a parallel
between Imaging and that they both use
light to tell a story The stained glass
and imaging both use light to tell a
story and also my friend Stefan so
there's a friendship component there too
he worked and we iterated he's such a
wizard he put that together in a
cathedral Cathedral and so that was very
inspiring and then I also want to tell
you that it was actually rejected as we
submitted as a cover for pnas for
original Ibex paper and it was rejected
so you know uh so if for any of you
feeling that out there you know but then
I I was pretty faithful honestly I was
like you know what let me just wait and
then it was selected as a cover for
nature methods and a special issue
related to Multiplex Imaging that we
authored with our hubmap colleagues so
delete is not a denial and so it's very
encouraging and I hope you are
encouraged uh by that so we never hear
what you know the story behind the story
um so really excellent question uh the
Nathan thank you Nathan
um is there Standard Process you follow
for selecting Imaging Channel and
imaging round to place a marker in your
panel this is a really excellent
question I wish there were rules and we
kind of want to develop a set of rules
um so certainly I can tell you the O
Maps those organ mapping antibody panels
you know it's a solved problem that's
how we're you know you go through all
the iteration this antibody needs to
come here you need to amplify it test
test so you know
so that's what we want to achieve that
that that's to solve proof but the
answer is I mean many of the things such
as with flow cytometry dim marker pair
it with a bright fluorophore right put
it in a 647 or 594 or channels that
don't have a lot of autofluorescence
also become a tissue Whisperer you know
you you stare at your tissues for so
long you'll realize okay in the lung for
the Alexa floor 488s you really need to
have a bang or antibody
um you you might need to amplify that
and if that's true you need to put those
uh indirect antibodies in earlier Cycles
because you don't want to have cross
reactivity with host species so it's a
really excellent question we do want to
on the Imaging Community you know
there's so many my to-do list overflows
and then ziv's to-do list overflows but
um just to have some rules and tips and
tricks uh um so that's a really
excellent question
um and uh so another one with Nathan
with Edge effects so I see your question
Nathan about asking the technical
question with Edge effects I think I'm
understanding that to mean that are you
segmenting cells when they're on the
perimeter of the image
um you know what I can I I can I know
that we can mask we mask the image that
we the area of the image that we
actually want to do our analysis on to
avoid the edge effect if I'm
understanding your question correctly
but the cool thing about the discussion
forum is that I can Port all these
questions into the GitHub discussion and
we can create a thread there and and
hopefully members of the community can
can help you and offer suggestions so I
appreciate that and then another
question are we integrating with spatial
transcriptomics
um yeah so I am not personally but this
is again the rewards of the community is
that there's a very excited and very
passionate Italian PhD student uh
Giuseppe so shout out who is you know
he's reached out and saying that he
wants to take this uh under you know and
he wants to push us forward and so cheer
everyone cheer him on and send uh Good
Good Vibes and positivity
um definitely it's very possible I think
there's a consideration about how you
fix and prepare your tissue I know other
colleagues in the Germain lab uh Vivian
and shushin uh and Wing Jing are
interested in looking at RNA and protein
in the same tissues as well so to be
determined but that's an excellent
question because there's really power in
integrating uh you know doing multimodal
so uh and there are other questions I'll
wait for the prompts from the presenter
um if I should should ask those so I'll
wait
go ahead okay great go ahead
um so the biggest challenge is I think
hopefully for adopting Ibex I I hope
that um We spelled it out that there's
some challenges that are just Universal
to multiplexed Imaging abandon all hope
no I'm kidding I'm kidding but uh that
at the time and costs and how we want to
work together to reduce those challenges
I think for Ibex and and certainly we
could we could pose this question for
members of the community and postpac
students I you know it's iterative so
iterative equals tedious you know I
think it's a full disclosure you know
it's I think the mountain is very apt
because it's a climb with any of these
methods uh it's a climb and so that's
why
um so iterative means you're gonna go
around and around the mountain and so I
would say that it's simple but not easy
and that's where you know with these
Multiplex Imaging that's where the value
of communities you form a support group
you say okay I'm not I'm not doing
something wrong this is just how it goes
so my colleague John Hickey in the Nolan
lab Gary Nolan's lab you know the Codex
Fame and Stanford Fame he's done a lot
in this space and you know just the
other day he told me it takes some 20
hours per sample to process an image
from start to annotation so anyway it's
uh
there's a lot of challenges and we hope
to work together to address them uh
thank you
uh
okay is there doing great okay is again
uh um
uh there's another question
um is community reagent resources to be
commonplace in Labs with a wide
contributor base I mean things just to
be passionate about it for one and also
realizing you know this is a
conversation that I had with Alexandra
NABA who started the nature Zone project
which is excellent
um is that uh
it's you have to love to do it it's
challenging and these are passion
projects or becomes your hobby because
you don't really get funding for these
initiatives even though we can see that
they are impactful so we operate on a
skeleton crew and honestly my mother has
helped so much and of course members of
the community but my mother who's
retired a public educator shout out mom
who's watching but she likes to say is a
hidden figure
um she's getting the metadative the rid
so it's just that the challenge I think
is that we're all so busy we want to
work on science that really leads to
Discovery and get those you know papers
out but the time to curate these
resources you know we don't get more
time or money to do it so you really
have to want to do it and then see the
value in it but I'm really grateful for
people like you and Josh and others on
the call for doing that so a question
from Sarah from Notre Dame is it is the
like a cell dive indispensable in the
Imaging step I'm assuming this is the
Tau sense function using the pulse laser
for single separation okay so first I'm
government employee so I can't endorse
any Technologies in our papers we have
used the lycoconfocal that was
originally the sp8 was used for Ibex
manual so we're using a confocal system
that did not have Tau sense we were
using the Leica Thunder which is a wide
field instrument that does not have tile
sense so it's not the cell dive does not
have that functionality but the the more
advanced sbas do that that so no we
don't need it it's not instead we do
sequential separation we choose our
fluorophores correct carefully and we're
working and we do dye compensation so to
get that high number of markers in a
cycle it is how you set up the image you
can do the confocal wide field cell dive
and I we want to publish how we set up
our image configurations for the
confocal and wide field and display that
on the knowledge base soon there's a
great postdoc who's working on the die
separation to to provide more details on
how to do that so so no it is not that's
a long answer to and no the cell dive is
not why we use that and we've used many
many instruments and we have people
using other microscope manufacturers
okay so I think
I think we're good
are there any more questions or
okay
great thank you guys really a pleasure
to connect with all of you and check us
out in the discussion uh the GitHub
discussion and have a lovely day
great well thank you so much Andrea
um we did have a few technical issues
with our audio here so she wasn't able
to hear me so thank you so much for
going through those questions and
getting those answers out we really
appreciate it
um so I want to thank you again Andrea
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Leica Microsystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast now before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you had
provided at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labroots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay so we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
everyone take care goodbye